y
[Música]
rusia intensifica los bombardeos contra
la acería de as of salem mariupol
mientras que los ucranianos siguen su
contraofensiva para recordar recuperar
jarquín y por primera vez desde el
inicio de la guerra los secretarios de
defensa de rusia y eeuu hablaron
telefónicamente
policías israelíes arremetieron contra
los palestinos que asistían al funeral
de la periodista asesinada chilling abu
aquel y se justificaron diciendo que
primero les lanzaron piedras la unión
europea la onu y eeuu condenaron la
violencia
las feministas estadounidenses siguen
rechazando la posible derogación del
derecho al aborto en el país en esta
misión les contaremos la historia de
varias de las mujeres que serían más
violentadas si se prohíbe la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle y
comenzamos con la actualidad del día 79
de la guerra en ucrania los rusos
intensificaron sus bombardeos contra la
acería de azov talent mariupol donde
está el último bastión de los militares
ucranianos la vice primera ministra
ucraniana irina bereziuk sólo dijo que
las negociaciones están muy difíciles
con moscú para intercambiar prisioneros
por quienes quedan en la planta por otro
lado en medio de la contraofensiva de
las tropas de kiev para intentar
recuperar la región de jarquín los rusos
respondieron bombardeando un centro
humanitario y los ucranianos asestaron
un golpe en la región pro rusa del
donbass allí destruyeron un puente
flotante y partes de una columna
blindada en el río iberski donest y en
paralelo a lo que ocurre en terreno
avanzan los diálogos por primera vez
desde el inicio de la guerra el
secretario de defensa de eeuu lloyd
austin mantuvo una conversación
telefónica de este viernes con su
homólogo ruso serguéi shoigú para
pedirle un alto al fuego
y los ministros de agricultura y de
exteriores de los países del g7 se
reúnen en stuttgart a alemania allí
discuten temas como el abastecimiento y
el aumento de los precios de los
alimentos en todo el mundo también se
refirieron a la responsabilidad de
vladimir putin en los daños que ha
causado la guerra
la creciente preocupación por la subida
de los precios de los alimentos a nivel
mundial uno de los principales temas de
la cumbre de los ministros de exteriores
y de agricultura del g7 en stuttgart
alemania con el ministro de agricultura
ucraniano como invitado especial of
trata por selene
las pérdidas de trigo pueden ser muy
importantes esperamos que las pérdidas
de la cosecha de maíz sean
proporcionalmente menores pero tenemos
que esperar y ver cómo se desarrollan
todos los factores en los próximos meses
y es que con la invasión rusa ucrania
las exportaciones mundiales de trigo y
aceite de girasol se han visto muy
afectadas ya que antes de la guerra el
90% de estas exportaciones salía desde
el mar negro ucraniano naciones unidas
ya ha advertido del alto riesgo para la
seguridad alimentaria mundial y varios
países del g7 sostienen que vladimir
putin tiene una responsabilidad directa
sobre el abastecimiento alimentario y
también sobre los daños materiales
causados por la guerra
entonces hasta
andrés he pedido a los países del g7 que
adopten la legislación y pongan en
marcha todos los procedimientos
necesarios para confiscar los activos
soberanos rusos y dárselos a ucrania
para reconstruir nuestro país
to rebuild alcance mientras los países
vecinos de rusia han visto sus economías
fuertemente afectadas por el conflicto y
piden protección y moldavia es el vecino
más frágil de ucrania tenemos una serie
de efectos negativos para nuestro país a
causa de esta guerra en la esfera
económica y humanitaria
hemos tenido una enorme ola de
refugiados y un miedo que va más allá de
lo económico ya que en los últimos días
ha aumentado el temor a que la guerra
llegue a moldavia después de que los
separatistas pro rusos de la región
moldava de transnistria
culparán aquí de explosiones con drones
en la frontera y precisamente el
incremento de los precios se padece en
irán
allí la inflación anual alcanzó el 40% y
el gobierno anunció el jueves un aumento
del 300 por ciento en el precio de
productos como el aceite de cocina el
pollo los huevos y la leche y varios
iraníes protestaron contra la inflación
y critican a través de las redes
sociales las políticas gubernamentales
enteran los escaparates de esta
panadería son engañosos el suministro de
trigo se ve interrumpido en el país como
resultado el coste de la producción y el
precio de venta de estos panes se
disparan
hay un descenso del 20 por ciento en las
ventas la cesta de la compra de la gente
es cada vez más pequeña el precio de la
harina se ha multiplicado por 10 antes
comprábamos harina por 700.000 reales
pero ahora cuesta casi 7 millones
las sequías las sanciones
internacionales y ahora la invasión de
rusia ucrania está repercutiendo en el
coste de las importaciones de productos
básicos el jueves el gobierno iraní
anunció otra fuerte subida de precios
hasta un 300 por ciento de aumento en
algunos productos alimentarios
y la gente no puede permitirse productos
básicos y comidas sencillas tú como
hombre o mujer que cuida de su familia
como diablos vas a poder permitirte el
coste de la vida y que le vas a contar a
tus hijos
que la clase baja solía comer macarrones
en lugar de carne y pollo ahora incluso
estos macarrones son retirados de su
mesa
los macarrones se han convertido en el
símbolo de un creciente malestar en el
país en twitter muchos internautas son
irónicos al publicar platos cotidianos
que se han convertido en signos
ostentosos de riqueza pero la esperanza
de días mejores podrían venir de un
acuerdo entre teherán y las potencias
mundiales para levantar algunas de las
sanciones impuestas al país el viernes
la unión europea dijo que las
conversaciones nucleares iraníes
bloqueadas hasta ahora han sido
reabiertas occidente enfrentando a la
guerra de ucrania busca la manera de
prescindir del petróleo y el gas rusos
irán uno de los principales productores
del mundo parece ser una opción a tener
en cuenta un posible ingreso que caería
como una bendición para teherán
policías israelíes golpearon y le
lanzaron granadas de aturdimiento a los
palestinos que asistían al entierro de
la periodista asesinada sirin abu aquel
incluso patearon a las personas que
cargaban el ataúd y éste casi se cae el
funeral se realizaba en la ciudad vieja
de jerusalén para despedir a la
reportera palestino estadounidense a la
que le dispararon mientras cubría una
redada de las fuerzas israelíes en la
cisjordania ocupada
el cortejo fúnebre de sirena a boa click
apenas había comenzado antes de que la
situación se convirtiera en un caos en
un aparente esfuerzo por forzar la
procesión en coche la policía israelí
cargó contra la multitud golpeando a los
portadores del féretro con implementos
antidisturbios
en un momento dado el grupo casi dejó
caer el ataúd mientras estallaban
granadas de aturdimiento
[Aplausos]
un funcionario israelí dijo que los
dolientes habían lanzado piedras y
botellas de vidrio la unión europea se
mostró consternada por lo que calificó
de comportamiento desproporcionado
mientras que la casa blanca calificó las
escenas de profundamente perturbadoras
este es un día en el que todos
deberíamos conmemorar incluyendo a todos
los presentes la memoria de una notable
periodista que perdió la vida lamentamos
la internación en lo que debería haber
sido una procesión pacífica tras haber
informado sobre el conflicto
palestino-israelí durante más de dos
décadas agua clic se había convertido en
un nombre conocido
los dolientes abarrotaron la catedral de
jerusalén para el servicio fúnebre y
miles de personas escoltaron su ataúd
hasta el cementerio con la idea de
estamos todos unidos la cantidad de
gente que hay aquí muestra como siren
unía a todos los palestinos de todas las
ciudades
he venido aquí para rendir homenaje a
una mujer honorable que nos representó
durante más de 25 años ella era nuestra
voz ante el mundo y esta voz ha sido
arrebatada la muerte de la periodista de
51 años provocó la indignación de los
palestinos
condena de la comunidad internacional ya
también ciudadano estadounidense fue
asesinada a tiros mientras informaba
sobre una redada israelí en la
cisjordania ocupada el miércoles
hablemos ahora de américa este viernes
las autoridades colombianas enviaron a
paraguay el cuerpo del fiscal contra el
crimen organizado marcelo pecci quien
fue asesinado el 10 de abril en la isla
colombiana de varus mientras celebraba
su luna de miel sicarios llegaron en
motos acuáticas hasta la playa privada
donde estaba y le dispararon pecho
investigado a varios casos contra el
narcotráfico y el terrorismo en su país
para hablar del panorama del crimen
organizado en paraguay nos acompaña
jeremy mcdermott codirector ejecutivo y
cofundador de insightcrime señor
mcdermott un placer saludarlo cómo se
vinculan el narcotráfico de paraguay con
el resto de américa latina y por qué
importa ese país en este sentido
es paraguay es el primer productor de
marihuana de américa del sur y la mayor
parte de su producción es para el
mercado de brasil con respecto a la
cocaína pues eso esto narcotráfico es
como el agua y va por el cómic al camino
de menor resistencia y hay muy poca
resistencia en paraguay entonces cocaína
de perú y bolivia pasa por paraguay
hacia brasil tiene un consumo interno
muy alto y hacia europa y una de las
mayores incautaciones de cocaína en
europa del año pasado de 11 toneladas en
el puerto de amberes en bélgica se
originó en paraguay uno de los casos más
conocidos en los que estaba trabajando
marcelo pecci fue el llamado operativo a
ultranza pib que es uno de los más
grandes en paraguay en contra del
narcotráfico que nos puede usted hablar
de ese caso y que muestra de los
vínculos con el narcotráfico con bolivia
colombia y europa países que usted es
mencionado anteriormente
sí
fue una de las operaciones antidrogas
más grandes en la historia de paraguay
involucrando a la tea a europol a la
policía de paraguay y uruguay resultó en
la incautación de unos 100 millones de
dólares en activos y la captura de más
de 20 personas también expuso los
vínculos entre el narcotráfico y el
mundo político en paraguay
y el fiscal
pezzi pues estaba involucrado a parte de
esta operación prácticamente con
respecto a las mafias de brasil y
precisamente hablando de las mafias de
brasil pezzi también investigó a la
llamada organización criminal brasileña
primer comando da capital que tan
fuertes son los grupos armados
brasileños en paraguay
pues el psc es ahora la estructura de
crimen organizada más grande de brasil
con más de 10 mil miembros
nacida en el brutal sistema
penitenciario de brasil inicialmente
entre el involucró en el micro tráfico
de drogas pero en los últimos cuatro o
cinco años se ha convertido en una
organización transnacional con presencia
en bolivia y en paraguay traficando
cocaína no sólo para el mercado
brasileño sino para exportar a europa
jeremy mcdermott gracias por este
análisis aquí en france 24
con gusto y pasamos a otras noticias
porque las feministas estadounidenses
continúan manifestándose en contra de lo
que podría ser la derogación del derecho
al aborto en el país y es que la
discusión pública no ha cesado desde que
se filtró a los medios de comunicación
un borrador de la sentencia de la corte
suprema de justicia
estadounidense en la que aparentemente
anularía la decisión del caso roe versus
wade que garantiza el derecho al aborto
en todo eeuu desde 1973 víctimas de
abusos sexuales exponen sus casos para
visibilizar el retroceso y como la
prohibición vulneraría los derechos de
millones de mujeres marina sardenya nos
cuenta la historia
de beta tenía 16 años y soñaba con
entrar al ejército cuando un reclutador
la violó quedó embarazada de su agresor
pero pudo acceder a un aborto gracias al
derecho que le otorgaba la sentencia roe
versus wade
quedé embarazada como resultado de una
violación y simplemente decidí que no
quería cuidar al niño o incluso tener el
bebé porque simplemente no estaba en el
estado emocional adecuado para tener un
hijo que vino de una violación
efe/madrid su historia es una más entre
las miles de mujeres que han sido
víctimas de agresiones sexuales en eeuu
y que tras ello decidieron abortar
teniendo así una segunda oportunidad una
vida más digna ahora ellas alzan la voz
contando sus casos para denunciar como
la eventual prohibición de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
pondría en vilo a los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres del país de
hasta 30% que la corte suprema no es el
lugar para tomar una decisión sobre mi
cuerpo en el mapa de la penalización del
aborto discrimina aún más a las mujeres
de contextos vulnerables o de
comunidades afro indígenas inmigrantes
poniendo en riesgo sus vidas después de
que fracasara un intento por codificar
el derecho al aborto en el senado este
viernes los demócratas llamaron a los
estadounidenses a defender el aborto
sobre liverpool en círculos republicanos
de todo el país ya se están movilizando
en torno a una agenda peligrosa y
extrema para criminalizar todas las
formas de atención sanitaria
reproductiva incluyendo la ive la
anticoncepción y la atención post aborto
sin escala richter las activistas
feministas están organizando marchas
masivas en cuatro ciudades del país
nueva york chicago los ángeles y
washington y movilizaciones hasta el
verano cuando se espera se conozca el
fallo del tribunal supremo que daría los
estados la potestad de decidir
individualmente sus políticas con
respecto al aborto así llegamos al final
de nuestra emisión informativa los
invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24 ya que consulten más en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom y en todas
nuestras redes sociales nosotros nos
vemos en minutos
[Música]